اسمعوني جيدا. سنريكم الويل
باسلحة مرعبة حتى الامريكان لا
يمتلكونها ولن ترى اوكرانيا
النور بعدها. قالها بوتين بغضب
وزينسكي والناتو يردون. الولايات
المتحدة تنشر قواتها ومنظومات
صواريخها مجددا قرب روسيا
والبنتاجون يعطي الضوء الاخضر
لاوكرانيا والغرب تشتعل يا سادة
فكيف سيرد الروس يا ترى كادت ان
تذهب في مهب الريح فما الذي
يجري? واشنطن ترد بقوة على
اجتماع الصين والسعودية. وبكين
تقدم للرياض سلاحا يستطيع الوصول
الى واشنطن والجزائر تتقدم قمة
العرب مع الرئيس الصيني بما
تركيا تمضي بضرباتها في سوريا
وتتفاوض مع العراقيين. حروب
الوعيد. الرئيس الروسي بوتين
صبره ويعلن عن امكانية تعديل
العقيدة العسكرية لبلاده من اجل
اتاحة تنفيذ ضربة استباقية لنزع
سلاح العدو اي ان النووي الروسي
لن يكون فقط من اجل الدفاع
والردع بل من اجل الهجوم ايضا
ويا له من جنون يفزع العالم.
بوتين عاد واكد ان صواريخ بلاده
وانظمة التي تفوق سرعة الصوت
اكثر حداثة لا بل واكثر كفاءة من
التي تمتلكها الولايات المتحدة
فلماذا كل هذا التفاخر يا ترى
فورا خرج الامين العام لحلف
الناتو وعبر عن قلقه من ان تخرج
الحرب الاوكرانية عن نطاق
السيطرة لتصبح حربا بين روسيا
والناتو قائلا. لا شك في ان هناك
حربا شاملة ستحدث بين روسيا
والناتو. نعم ذلك هو احتمال. لكن
المستشار الالماني كان سبق
ستولتنبرغ قائلا ان روسيا تراجعت
عن تهديداتها باستخدام نووي في
الاونة الاخيرة معتبرا ان هذا
التراجع هو نتيجة لواقع ان
المجتمع الدولي رسم خطا احمر
لموسكو بشأن تهديدها النووي.
ليمنح البنتاجون الضوء الاخضر
لاوكرانيا لشن ضربات تستهدف
الداخل الروسي. وبحسب صحيفة
بريتش تايمز فقد عدلت امريكا
تقييمها لموسكو ولم تعد من الرد
الروسي في حال تكررت الضربات
الاوكرانية للعمق الروسي. ومن
حرب اشارات المرور الى حرب
التوقعات. هنا الرئيس الاوكراني
يقول ان الحرب يمكن ان تنتهي في
الفين وثلاثة وعشرين. ياتي الرد
سريعا من الكريملين ان الحرب
يمكن ان تنتهي غدا اذا اراد
زيلنسكي ذلك. لكن موسكو اتهمت
واشنطن بالسعي لاطالة امد الصراع
حتى وخمسة وعشرين. فلماذا هذا
الوقت بالتحديد? وبالعودة للحرب
ذاتها. فقد توعد بوتين اوكرانيا
وبشدة بمواصلة ضرب منشآت الطاقة
فيها ردا على هجمات كييف كما قال
لاسيما في شبه جزيرة القرم. ليرد
زلانسكي ان حكومته تعمل على رفع
معدلات الامداد الكهربائي بشكل
مستمر لكنها تواجه صعوبات في
استعادة الامداد الكهربائي
بالكامل. زلنسكي اكد ان قوات
روسيا دمرت مدينة باخموت بالكامل
وهي احدى اكثر المناطق اشتعالا
في جبهة دومباس. هنا ياتي
الاسعاف الامريكي باعلان
الولايات المتحدة انها سترسل
مساعدات عسكرية اضافية عاجلة
لاوكرانيا وبقيمة مائتين وخمسة
وسبعين مليون دولار وتتضمن قذائف
لمنظومة عربات عسكرية ومولدات
كهربائية، والهدف هو حماية
واضاءة سماء اوكرانيا بحسب
رويترز. بينما عاد الرئيس
الاوكراني ليكشف عن صيغة سلام
تشمل عشر نقاط بينها الامن
النووي واستعادة وحدة الاراضي
الاوكراني ليجتمع بوتين بحلفائه
في قمة الاتحاد الاقتصادي
الاوراسي ويعلنها ملامح نظام
عالمي الاقطاب تولد الان امام
اعيننا بشكل فعلي في اسيا
وافريقيا وامريكا اللاتينية حيث
يجري هناك تشكيل مراكز جديدة
للتنمية التي تدافع بشكل متزايد
عن مصالحها الوطنية وتحمي
سيادتها. واتهم بوتين الغرب
بتحويل الشعب الاوكراني الى ما
وصفه بوقود لمواجهة روسيا وذلك
يزيد من احتمالات الصراع في حسب
قوله. فيما يلعب الامريكان مع
الروس سرا من تحت الطاولة حيث
تجري واشنطن وموسكو اتصالات
دبلوماسية في اسطنبول. ليؤكد
الروس ان الاتصالات مع الامريكان
خصصت لمناقشة القضايا التي تثير
قلق الطرفين يحيى بذلك امل في
عودة علاقات البلدين الى وضعها
الطبيعي بحسب نائب وزير الخارجية
سيرجي رياكول. ليقر مجلس النواب
الامريكي اكبر ميزانية دفاع في
العالم ثمن مائة وثمانية وخمسين
مليار دولار لعام الفين وثلاثة
وعشرين. وبزيادة خمسة واربعين
مليار دولار عن الميزانية التي
اقترحها الرئيس جو بايدن. لكن
ماذا لو كانت هذه المليارات تذهب
في الجانب الانساني? لعاش العالم
في سلام يا هؤلاء ولعشتم دون قلق
او خوف. وبشأن الخوف هناك حركت
امريكا قواتها قرب حدود روسيا
فبعد ايام من عقدها اكبر صفقة
سلاح مع واشنطن قالت الدفاع
الاستونية ان الولايات المتحدة
الامريكية تعتزم نشر قوات مشاة
اضافية في استونيا خلال الاسابيع
المقبلة وذلك لتعزيز الدفاعات
على الجناح الشرقي لحلف شمال
الاطلسي الناتو. وكانت استونيا
وقعت عقدا لشراء ست منظومات
صاروخية امريكية من طراز لقاء
مائتي مليون دولار ومن حرب
واشنطن وموسكو الباردة الى حرب
تم اطفاؤها سريعا. نيويورك تايمز
تعلنها. المخطط الانقلابي في
المانيا لم يكن يقتصر فقط على
اقتحام مقر البرلمان بل شمل
اغتيال رئيس الدولة المستشار
اولف شولدز وعدد من المشرعين.
الصين تقترب من العرب. شيئا
فشيئا يتجمع الولايات المتحدة
لكنهم لا يكتفون بتجمعهم. وها هي
بكين تمنح السعودية صاروخ العابر
للقارات والذي يمكن الصينيين من
استهداف واشنطن ولندن وابعد
منهما خلال دقائق. بهذه الصواريخ
نجحت الصين في حجز مقعد متقدم
لها على المسرح الدولي ليس
تجاريا فحسب بل عسكريا ايضا.
لننتقل الى القمة عربية الصينية.
حيث تولي بكين اهمية كبيرة
للجزائر باستثمارات كبيرة للصين
هناك. ويظهر ذلك جليا بقيام
الصينيين ببناء الجامع الاعظم
المقام على ارض العاصمة
الجزائرية. والمعروف بكونه ثالث
اكبر مسجد في العالم بعد الحرمين
الشريفين بالسعودية. اصحاب
العيون الضيقة لا يتقربون من
الجزائر عبثا. فالجزائر تعد اكبر
نفطي في شمال افريقيا واحد اكبر
منتجي النفط بالقارة وهي شريك
استراتيجي للصين منذ حقبة
تاريخية تتجاوز النصف قرن. الرد
الامريكي على قمة الصين والعرب
سيكون في تايوان. فبعد اقراره
ميزانية ضخمة للدفاع وافق مجلس
النواب الامريكي على مشروع قانون
ينص على منح مساعدات عسكرية
ومبيعات اسلحة الى تايوان بقيمة
مليارات دولار ولا ندري اهي
مساعدات ام ان واشنطن ترفض
اقتصادها بمليارات تايوان.
الاتراك لا تنطفئ نارهم. الاتراك
لا يتوقفون ولا يكلون ولا يميلون
من هجماتهم على جيرانهم لتعلن
القوات التركية توسع دائرة
اهدافها في الشمال السوري بينما
ردت قوات سوريا الديموقراطية
باستهداف محيط قاعدة تركية في
منطقة كفر جنة بعدة صواريخ. وها
هو الرئيس التركي اردوغان يعلن
ان بلاده مصممة على مكافحة
الارهاب وانهائه اينما وجد.
مضيفا ان تركيا تمتلك القدرة على
تحقيق انتصارات لا يتوقعها احد
حسب تعبيره. ليرد الامريكان وعلى
لسان المتحدث باسم الخارجية
الولايات المتحدة مستمرة في
تركيا كحليف مهم في الناتو في
مواجهة الارهاب الذي تتعرض له.
لكن الروس ارسلوا وفدا خاصا الى
تركيا ليبحث مع المسؤولين
الاتراك ملف المصالحة بين انقرة
ودمشق. وامكانية عقد لقاء يجمع
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان وبشار
الاسد قبل الانتخابات الرئاسية
والبرلمانية التركية. هناك رد
الاتراك انهم يدرسون المقترح
الروسي الذي عرض قوات سوريا
الديموقراطية من منبج وعين العرب
في الشمال السوري. فهل تنتهي
عملية تركيا البرية بالتفاوض؟
وبين هذا وذاك انطلقت مفاوضات
عراقية تركية لوقف الضربات على
الاراضي العراقية ليقول وزير
الخارجية العراقي فؤاد حسين ان
الحوار مع تركيا وايران يهدف
لحماية السيادة العراقية ومنع
استهداف دول الجوار. الاحد
والتطورات. هيئة البث
الاسرائيلية سقوط خرائط عسكرية
كانت بحوزة جنود الاحتلال في
جنين ونشرها فلسطينيون على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي. بريطانيا
تواجه فوضى الاضرابات مجددا بعد
مظاهرات حاشدة لموظفي البريد في
لندن. فتاة سورية تضحك باستمرار
وتقهقه حتى يغمى عليها وهكذا
طيلة لكن مهلا هذه ليست سعادة
وانما بسبب مرض ماهر. موسكو
وكييف تحددان موعد انتهاء الحرب.
فهل اصابهما الملل بعد كل تلك
الخسائر دون فائدة?